I'm one of the few people you ever meet
in your whole life
who is impervious to the pain caused by
eating too much ice whoa okay this is
the kind of ice they use to pad your
drinks you get less soda yeah you want
something that just really crumbles in
your mouth it's kind of ice it sticks
together
look at that what is - dude you're nice
this is the hot ice yeah there's some
top-shelf it's like snow
they're easy to chew all of a crunch
it's just nice to look at they're all
perfectly round I gotta say though it
still does the clumping thing where it
all at one of reasons together and it's
in the face and all I student know what
Carol oh yeah they're little any bitty
meaning cubes what are they it was
pretty good this is in between a good
cube and around night and it sounds
really good
it's the kind that when you're using a
straw I get stuck good boy hey I'm mad
that happens this is easily the best of
all the ices can't put this in my mouth
that's not the point he uses your wish
it melts it at a good rate but it also
doesn't water - it's an edible this is
both not edible what are you six this
makes me want whiskey right now a
jesters
you
feel like Frank Sinatra's some grown-up
Cass ice wife so hard to look at it
doesn't even have any shape what a
deceptive ice I don't know where it was
from but they perfected the round view
is from the gutter his were thrown whoa
Donald's ice was garbage too hard too
hard and the commercials it looks great
though you know you gotta sometimes
think about what the ice goes in hello
that was super faceoff make me thank you
big mini kills are great is chick-fil-a
this blows my mind because the context
of that ice is so different that's
paying you see that changes the whole
game
the best ice is ice that never gets
noted and what a thankless job is it
that I have lots of stumble you I I
never talked about feel like most people
do